en septembre dernier après le décès de
la Reine Elizabeth son fils Charles
devient roi et l'une de ses dernières
décisions en tant que nouveau roi
d'Angleterre c'est ça
pour rappel contrairement à son fils la
reine Elisabeth elle adorait le foie
gras elle en avait même déjà mangé avec
François Hollande lors d'un repas à
l'Elysée je lève mon verre en l'honneur
de Votre Majesté et si le roi Charles a
choisi d'interdire le foie gras des
tables des résidences royales c'est
parce qu'il militent depuis longtemps
pour une agriculture bio et pour le
bien-être animal alors comprenez-vous sa
décision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que voilà le gavage
industriel
maintenant je pense qu'il y a des
éleveurs qui font ça dans les règles de
l'art exactement il y a moins de mal
dans la nature un peu voilà
tu fais pas de leçons quand tu fais de
la chasse à courres bien joué exactement
paradoxe complet il a aucune crédibilité
alors que l'image qu'on a dans notre
tête tout ce qu'on a tous c'est lui avec
son fusil avec ses cheveux
c'est pour ça que c'est terrible
c'est les chiens en fait on fatigue
jusqu'à ce qu'elle se fait qu'elle meurt
de sa vie cardiaque et une femme quand
on est face à chasseur à court c'est
d'aller finir la bête avec un couteau
un petit précision parce que en fait
depuis des années le foie gras est
interdit de production en
Grande-Bretagne
et c'est pour ça qu'en fait en fait
c'est de la com parce qu'il est en quête
de popularité d'opinion faveur d'ici à
son sacre au mois de mars prochain
couronnement il est là il ne fait que ça
tout ce qu'il fait actuellement c'est
pour être le avoir le plus d'opinion
favorables possible et ça en fait c'est
un leurre c'est c'est est-ce que vous
avez pourquoi est-ce qu'il est comme ça
parce qu'avec la série de Netflix
de quoi on sous-entend que le le rachat
l'avait essayé de faire appliquer la oui
mais sa mère
écoutez
alors vous vous en savez rien
le premier celui qui est accusé de
comploter avec lui le Premier ministre a
dit mais non c'est totalement faux alors
Magalie
s'il avait laissé justement parce que tu
interdis aux oies de d'Angleterre de
faire enfin de de subir anglaise oui
voilà de subir ça mais par contre ceux
de France il y a pas de problème et on
fait de l'importation c'est c'est c'est
enfin non soit tu le fais soit tu le
fais pas tu le prends pas les autres je
suis désolé il a bien fait et puis en
plus moi j'avais vu un reportage un jour
sur ça j'avais arrêté de manger du foie
gras
c'est dégueulasse oh non c'est vraiment
industriel tout ça c'est après
dans la dans les règles de l'art ou
c'est moi moi traumatisant voilà c'est
une tradition française et encore des
gens qui travaillent dans les usines qui
travaillent dans les fermes repas donc
voilà euh tout interdire ils vont mettre
combien de gens sur sur le carreau c'est
vrai oui
et les éleveurs et donc j'ai pas du tout
l'impression de tourner les éleveurs qui
sont en France ou en Angleterre en
revanche je trouve très dur sur le
prince Charles parce que très
sincèrement c'est un mec qui depuis des
décennies midi pour l'écologie alors sur
la chasse à courche est d'accord avec
Hugo tradition machin bidule à la con
mais en revanche
bonjour tu l'as toujours été très très
fidèle contre le tout béton contre eux
et moi je me trouve très à jujube parce
qu'il est pas antipathique du tout
il gagne des voix en Angleterre et ce
que vous appelez la vieille la Camila
pareil
ils arrêtent alors
raffolée justement de foie gras et
c'était souvent un sujet de discorde
lors des fêtes la reine l'avant enfin
Elisabeth
elle torterait beaucoup hein
comme Isabelle je vous trouve vraiment
très très dur avec le prince Charles
parce que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
attend pardon avec le roi Charles le roi
c'est vrai qu'on
attendait
alors
mais c'est goûter mais c'est vrai que le
le voilà on est perdu
alors moi je suis totalement dans votre
team comme comme très souvent moi mon
problème en fait avec avec ce monsieur
c'est surtout dans la priorisation
d'action il y a tellement de choses à
faire c'est la priorisation d'action me
dit c'est génial bien sûr en train de
sombrer il y a 20% d'inflation
alors il a pas de pouvoir les
initiatives voilà mais je pense que déjà
pas le moral et dans toutes leurs
résidence et tout on leur servait pas du
foie gras bon marché je pense que ça
venait effectivement de producteurs très
sérieux c'était du foie gras pour
l'élite mais aussi pardon depuis la mort
de sa mère il y a l'Afrique du Sud qui
ne cesse de réclamer de récupérer le
plus gros diamant du monde qui aurait
été volé à l'époque de la colonisation
n'est-ce pas de britannique et il a
jamais pipé un mot
bah oui mais c'est normal les bijoux de
la reine des bijoux de la reine ils sont
inestimables
qui sont responsables mais comment vous
arrivez à gaver une noix naturellement
et bah vous lui demandez poliment voilà
merci beaucoup
je mange des graines j'ai tout mon cœur
c'est la patience voilà une petite
graine voilà et après le rajouter un
tout petit truc non s'il te plaît
un tout petit truc c'est que en fait son
cabinet au prince Charles a fait exprès
de contacter l'association péta pour que
l'association le communique et que ça
fasse du bruit donc c'est uniquement de
la com donc
toi le confort